you guys in chapter 229 is the chapter
where sukuna finally reveals himself to
be a complete and total fraud now don't
get me wrong in the fight with Gojo so
far I actually think that sukune has
been winning I mean they've been pretty
evenly matched most of the time but
overall I'd say tsukuda has had most of
the small wins up until this point
however as we're about to see in the
spoilers for chapter 229 it seems like
sukana knows that he isn't able to win
without using the power that he stole
from Mega me just before we get into it
I want to remind you guys at the very
beginning of the series sukin is set to
go Drew that he would kill him once he
got control of yuji's body so that was
sukuna basically saying that yeah I'm
strong enough to beat you I can do it
with my own technique you know I don't
need any other powers to defeat you now
it's seeming like that's not the case
but let's get into it so Jujitsu Kai is
in chapter 229 picks up immediately
where the last chapter left off where
goja was having a nosebleed now the
reason I think he was having a nosebleed
in that chapter is because he has been
pushing his curse at night to the Limit
because as we know you know he's done
three consecutive domain expansions and
on top of that he used reverse curse
technique to heal his burnt out curse
technique as a result he's pushing his
body to the absolute limit and so yeah
it makes sense why he'd have some kind
of negative reaction after doing all of
that now this new chapter begins with
you to noticing this and kind of getting
a bit worried but Gojo himself just
casually wipes the nosebleed away and he
doesn't really seem to care that much
following that goju and sukina then
activate their domain expansions for the
fourth time in a row which is insane and
yeah I mean baisuka doing this so
quickly what it shows is that he's also
using reverse curse technique to heal
his burnt out curse technique usually
when it comes to most people after
they've done one domain expansion
they're not able to use their curse
technique for a while but when it comes
to these two just by the way they can
use reverse curse technique they're able
to just go back to back to back to back
to back from the sidelines kusakabe
watches on as he just gives his
commentary and one of the things he says
is that if Gojo wants to win he has to
deal so much damage to Suki her that the
king of curses won't be able to maintain
his domain expansion one thing I should
point out about that is in the last
chapter when Godwin tsukuna were kind of
fighting each other that is exactly what
Gojo did he dealt so much damage to
sukuner that sukuna's domain collapsed
but the only problem in the last chapter
was that as Gojo did this tsukuna at the
same time destroyed his domain from the
outside so it was kind of like a
stalemate like Gojo did win but at the
same time sukuna won so nothing really
happened we then see that inside the
domain in this chapter godrej was just
going full Goblin mode at this point and
he just punches sukuna over and over and
over again and there is this one moment
where it seems like sukuna is able to
dodge it but then Gojo just throws him
straight into the malevolent Shrine Gojo
then uses his curse technique to
literally pull sukuna towards him again
and as he goes to land a punch this time
sukuna does block it with his two hands
one second later both of their domain
expansions then collapsed again at the
same time and from this we are actually
able to learn something pretty important
what we know now is that inside the
domain like just in side Gojo is
stronger than tsukuna period like
malevolent Shrine is not as powerful as
unlimited void we know that now because
when it comes to the clashes inside the
domain Gojo has now won two times in a
row anyway following the collapse of
their domains goju and sukina then once
again go to open domain expansion but
everyone notices that Gojo's domain was
expanded a tiny bit earlier now you
might be wondering why exactly this is
and the reason is pretty simple earlier
in the chapter when goju was just
punching up sukuna inside the domain
basically what happened with sukuna got
injured he got hurt and so sukuna just
took a little tiny microsecond to just
heal himself quickly with reverse curse
technique the problem though is that
baisukana using that brief amount of
time to heal himself go just been that
micro second healing his burnt out curse
technique this means that when it came
time to expand their domains Gojo had a
slight 0.01 second advantage and that
slight delay combined with the fact that
Gojo's domain is better on the inside it
meant that sukuna had miscalculated as a
direct consequence of that malevolent
Shrine doesn't last for very long I
think it lasts for about three minutes
this time around and it collapses on the
inside of Gojo's domain expansion now
this is amazing because basically what
it means is that sukuna is now he's now
unprotected he's just a man inside of
Gojo's domain and that means that you
know without the protection of his own
domain to fight against gojos tsukuna
finally gets hit with the effect of
unlimited voids in case you might have
forgotten a limited void basically just
sends I mean it's kind of in the name it
sends almost an unlimited amount of
information into a person's brain and
for most people the information overload
is just way too much and it leaves them
paralyzed in one of the panels for
chapter 229 we can see that sukina is
completely paralyzed like he's just
staring forward with a blank expression
basically in the same way that jogo was
way back in season one and In This
Moment Gojo rushes towards him with
basically the intention of killing him
and he thinks to himself that he's going
to crush sukina's heart lungs and liver
I mean to be fair sukina can survive
without certain organs I mean we know
that because he ripped out yuji's heart
and then he was just walking around like
nothing happened so suguna doesn't need
these organs to survive but if Gojo was
to do this and was to crush his heart
lungs and liver it's going to put sukuna
in a position where he has to use
reverse curse technique and again if
tsukuni uses reverse curse technique to
heal himself that just gives Gojo the
advantage because when sukin is healing
himself goju can do all sorts of things
he can activate his domain again he can
do whatever he wants however just when
things are looking good for Gojo sukuno
wakes up and he summons maharaga now
this is crazy I mean we've seen sukune
use maharaga before in his fight against
yorozu but this image right here I can't
show it on screen but this imagery of
Gojo just standing there and maharaga
towering over him like it's terrifying
like Gojo does look like an insect
compared to this just massive creature
now there's a couple things we need to
mention here the first is that the
reason sukune was able to wake up so
quickly and the reason why maharaga is
already adapted to unlimited void is
because in the last chapters tsukuna was
already laying the groundwork for this
to happen like we've seen before the
wheel in maharagus head is is basically
the key to everything because whenever
it makes a single turn it adapts to
whatever was happening before and so in
the last chapter when Gojo had his
unlimited void open and was attacking
sukuna sukuna was secretly using the
wheel to adapt to be honest we actually
don't know how long sukune was doing
this I mean in theory sukuna could have
been using the wield from the beginning
of the fight and we just never knew
because as we saw in the last chapter
the wheel was hidden in the shadow so no
one knew what was going on nobody knew
that he was adapting if Suka has been
using this from the very beginning
by now he's adapted to hollow purple
he's adapted to a curse technique
reversal red he's adapted to a limited
void he's adapted to all of Gojo's moves
and so when maharaga comes out now he
knows everything Gojo can do like sukin
has been letting Gojo do all of these
different things and letting maharaga
adapt to it so that when he finally
comes out in this chapter there's
nothing Gojo can do according to the
leaks Gojo is surprised when maharagus
suddenly comes out but he quickly gets
ready to destroy maharaga in a single
hit before it has the chance to get used
to unlimited void Gojo tries to use
curse technique reversal but maharaga
destroys Gojo's domain from the inside
the chapter then ends in that moment
with his domain being just wiped out
there's so much to say about this but I
guess the first thing is that if sukuna
feels like he can't win this fight
without using the strongest shikigami
from a curse technique that doesn't even
belong to him it just raises so many
questions because this guy he's meant to
be the best Sorcerer of all time and yet
by sukana bringing out maharaga you know
whether he wants to admit it or not
that's kind of him admitting that he's
not good enough to be Gojo by himself 10
Shadows is not his technique it belongs
to someone else so when he was talking
all that smack at the beginning of the
series about how he was going to beat
Gojo when he gets control of yuji's body
it has me thinking now if he had gotten
control of yuji's body fully would he
have beat Gojo because if he had control
of Yuji he would not have had Maharaja
he wouldn't have had the 10 Shadows it
would have just been malevolent Shrine
and in that scenario it looks like he
would have lost because he wouldn't have
been able to adapt to a limited void so
I think the fact that maharaga needs to
come out at this point it to me it
proves Beyond any doubt now that Gojo
would have won this battle if it was
fair and square however as we know it's
not fair and square sukina does have the
10 Shadows now so he is well within his
rights to unleash maharaga but I'm just
saying by doing this it just shows Point
Blank he wouldn't have won if he didn't
steal the 10 Shadows for Mega me now
putting that to the side for a second
what a Gojo's chances here now that
maharaga is out does Gojo have a chance
of survival
the answer to that depends on how long
sugan has been using the wheel if he's
been using the Wheel from the beginning
of the fight and he's adapted to you
know Hollow purple cursed at Nick
reversal red if maharaga has already
been adapted to all of those different
things
then the only way Gojo can win is if he
awakens something that's never been done
before within the Gojo family we know
that basically all of the moves we've
seen from Gojo have been done by someone
else before I think he even mentioned in
his fight against toji that Hollow
purple has been used by a couple other
people in the past so he didn't invent
that move but in this situation he
generally might have to invent something
that's never been done before because if
Maharaj is adapted to all his different
moves he has no other choice he either
has to invent something new or he's
gonna die it's as simple as that because
this shikigami is just way too strong
there's just no other way on the other
side though if maharaga's wheel was
really used for the first time in the
last chapter like if that generally was
the first time that sukuna had been
secretly using it then all it means is
that maharaga has adapted to Gojo's
domain and maybe to certain physical
attacks but beyond that you know goja
can still use red he can still use
hollow purple and he can still win but
um my suspicion is that suchuna has been
secretly using it from the very
beginning which which would mean that
yeah at this point Gojo has very limited
options I mean like I said he has to
make something up there's nothing left
at this point if sukuna wins I'm sure
some people will say that oh yeah sukun
is the better the better sorcerer but if
you just flip the script for a second if
Gojo went into this fight with with his
technique plus 10 Shadows against
tsukuna and Gojo one doing that
everyone would call him a fraud so I'm
sorry I have to say in this situation
sukuna is the fraud he is the fraud for
using someone else's technique to win a
fight that should have been an even
match
um but that is just my opinion on it I
am still I respect sukuna he is
obviously amazing but man this just
leaves a sour taste in the mouth
um but it is really cool to look at so I
guess there's that anyway people you
should know that next week there is not
going to be a new chapter of Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen I think the mag is taking a break
for at least one week but in two weeks
time we should be back so I'll see you
then until the next one peace out